let's take a look at our previous code
to load an image now remember it was
three lines of code to create an image
set a call back and then define the
source the first steps in writing an
asset manager would be to cash this
image once it's loaded so that duplicate
calls won't issue a reload but rather
would return the image we've already
loaded in memory to do this you're going
to implement the concept of a cache what
will happen is the first request will go
through and the data will be loaded when
it's loaded you'll add it to the cash
using some key value like its name so
that subsequent requests rather than
going out to disk or to the web we'll
check the cash first and return the
already loaded asset what I'd like you
to do is to modify the following code so
the asset loader checks the cash before
attempting to load the image now there's
a couple things to point out here is
that gcash offsets is actually a
dictionary object which means that you
need to specify a key and value when
accessing and referencing to it also
take note that here in the image onload
callback is where you need to do your
heavy lifting to push your data into
this cache object good luck